معنى حول الموضوع في الاستاذ جاسم الوسيم
الاحمر وسيم اهلا بك وسيم لو نتوقف معك
بدايه عند الهدف الحقيقي من هذا القرار
لقوت ولا الديمقراطيه من الوقف جميع انشطه
التنسيق مع قوه التحل في سوريا
الديمقراطيه تدرك ان الورقه القويه التي
بحوزتها ايذاء حلفائها وعلى راسهم
الولايات المتحده هي ورقه التعاون في
محاربه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وخاصه في
مساله حمايه السجون والمخيمات التي تضم
مقاتلين همم من تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
وافراد من هذا التنظيم ومن بينهم بطبيعه
الحال همم من جنسيات اوروبيه وغير اوروبيه
هذا القرار هو للضغط على الولايات المتحده
لكن ايضا الدول الاوروبيه من اجل اتخاذ
موقف اكثر حزما للثاني تركيا عن القيام
بعمليه عسكريه ومهاجمه قوى سوريا
الديمقراطيه في شمال سوريا صحيح ان كل
الدول تعارض الان يعني الولايات المتحده
الى الدول الاوروبيه هذه العمليه وحتى
روسيا لكن من وجهه نظر قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه هذه الفرصه مؤتيه لرفع
لممارسه نوع من الضغط للتلوح بورقه عدم
التعاون لهذه الدول لمحاوله تجنب عمليه
عسكريه لان ما يجري حسنيه بالنسبه لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه هو انها همم ايذاء
الاهداف المعلنه من قبل الخارطه الان على
الشاشه لمحاوله اقامه منطقه تسميها تركيا
منطقه امنه بعمق 30 كلم تستدعي همم
الدخول
بقوه اخراج هو سوريا الديمقراطيه من مدن
خاصه كوباني او رفعت او منبج طبعا هناك
ليس فقط سوريا الديمقراطيه لكن تركيا تريد
السيطره على هذه المناطق من اجل اقامه ما
تسميه الشريط امن بالنسبه لها تعرف ان هذه
العمليه تهدد مصير القوات سوريا
الديمقرايه بشكل خاص مثير دار التي هي
امام خيارات صعبه اما ان همم تقبل بشروط
التركيه التي تذهب الى حد ليس فقط ابعادها
من المنطق حتى حل الاداره الذاتيه او قرار
المواجهه العسكريه وبالتالي احتمال خساره
السيطره على مناطق اساء هذا الوضع تستخدم
ورقه الضغط هذه على الامريكيين على
الاوروبيين
وتحاول استفاده من ما يمكن قول انها فتره
همم فرصه للمفاوضات في الايام الاخيره مع
تراجع وتيره القصف الجوي وهمم صدور نوع من
المؤشرات انا العمليه العسكريه
ربما تاجلت ربما بانتظار قرارات سياسيه
ماء او مفاوضات مع روسيا والولايات
المتحده بشكل خاص من قبل تركيا
اوه تحديدا هو سؤال يطرح وسم بخصوص روسيا
نرى نوعا من الاسترشاد من قبل القنصليه
الديمقراطيه بموسكو ما الذي تقترح موسكو
تحديدا في هذه النقطه تقوم روسيا عمليه
بواسطات يعني على اكثر من خط الدرج الاولى
فيما يتعلق بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه هي
محاوله اقناع سوريا الديمقراطيه بالانسحاب
من مناطق وعوده الجيش السوري الى هذه
المناطق بما يسحب الذريعه من انقره للدخول
الى الشمال السوري لكن في وجهه نظاره
ذاتيه بشكل خاص تدرك ان هذا الامر قد يدفع
الى همم شيئا فشيئا الى مضطره بكل الاحوال
يتفاهم مع دمشق قد يدفع الى
تسويه سياسيه هي حتى الان لم تقتنع
بشروطها لانها تعتبر انها ستهدد ايضا
الاداره الذاتيه كان الاداره الذاتيه
بمعنى انها ستذهب الى حادث سياسي قد يقوم
على اقتراح همم امام قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه الى الكافراد الى جيش السوري
وحل الاداره الذاتيه عوده المؤسسات
الحكوميه هذا الامر ما زال همم قوه
الاداره التي قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
تراهن على دعم غربي للاستمرار بالوضع
الرهن واستمرارها في هذه المناطق لم يحسم
هذا الامر الخط الاخر لتعمل عليها عن همم
روسيا هي اعاده الدفء وهذا ما بدات بوادر
تظهر بين انقره ودمشق بحيث الان بدل
الحديث عن همم لقاء محتمل بين اردوغان
ونظيره السوري رغم كل ما جرى في السابق
رغم العدا ولم ينضج بعد لم تظهر باشتراك
هناك حديث روسي حديث تركي عن هذا الامر
دمشق تقول
لكن في حال نجحت هذه المساعي هذا يعني ان
ايضا ستكون هو السوره الديمقراطيه امام
خيار صعب للغايه خاصه في ظل انشغال
الحلفاء الاساسيه للاداره الذاتيه
للولايات المتحده الاوروبيه في اخر اي في
همم في اوكرانيا وحاجه كل هذه الدول عمليه
لتركيا في مواقف تتعلق باوكرانيا كما هناك
بطبيعه الحال العلاقه الروسيه التركيه
التي لا تطمئن الدول الغربيه